les deux militaires deux hommes
marchaient dans le stationnement de ce
petit centre commercial de
saint-jean-sur-richelieu vers 11h30 ce
matin quand subitement ils ont été
renversé par une automobile un des
militaires repose dans un état critique
l'autre a été légèrement blessé
l'automobiliste par la suite puis la
fuite avec des policiers à ses trousses
après une chasse à l'homme sur quelques
kilomètres l'automobiliste a perdu la
maîtrise de son véhicule qui a effectué
quelques tonneaux avant de se retrouver
dans ce fossé l'homme a réussi à sortir
de son véhicule avec un couteau à la
main menaçant les policiers qui l'ont
abattu de plusieurs coups de feu et j'ai
voulu sortir de l'auto pour aller aider
avant que les coups de feu partent c'est
quand que mon mari avant c'est un petit
peu comme dans le milieu ici c'est là
qu'ont entendu que j'ai vu j'ai entendu
les coups de feu sept coups de balles
j'ai vu un policier sauter comme ça ce
côté pour se protéger puis c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai vu le suspect tomber
par terre le suspect est un homme de 25
ans de saint jean sur richelieu c'est
quelqu'un qui est connu
des milieux policiers
entendus cette thèse de regarder
selon nos sources le suspect s'appelle
martin couture rouleau sur son site
facebook il s'identifie comme étant
ahmad rouleau et il fait l'éloge de
l'islam son entourage était d'ailleurs
au courant de sa conversion à l'islam
ben on savait qu'ils étaient convertis à
la religion du slam depuis plus d'un an
je
crois qu'il y avait des landes voisins
qui avaient des possiblement des
relations avec des gens de pays arabes
un drame qui soulève de nombreuses
questions et qui survient au moment où
le canada vient de s'engager dans la
guerre contre le groupe armé état
islamique issigeac bissonnet radio
canada c'est jean sur richelieu
oui manuel on a été assez surpris
aujourd'hui parce que très tôt dans la
journée il a été question je demande un
possible acte terroriste à la chambre
des communes oui céline sait vraiment où
commune que cette hypothèse a été émise
pour la première fois ceux ci produit
pendant la période des questions alors
que député conservateur a causé la
surprise en demandant au premier
ministre de commenter les événements qui
se déroulaient à
saint-jean-sur-richelieu je vous laisse
écouter les changes
d'abord par les cheveux
encore une fois monsieur le président du
centre ancien de ses abords du centre
est tout blanc nos pensées et nos
prières sont avec les victimes et des
familles vous serez en de près de la
situation et rendant disponible
maintenant céline ce qu'on ne savait pas
à ce moment là et qu'on a appris en
début de soirée c'est que lorsqu'il
prenait la parole aux communes monsieur
harper était au courant des détails de l
enquête il avait été informé par le
commissaire de la grc baup en scène par
le chef d'état major des forces
canadiennes dans un communiqué le bureau
de monsieur un peu indique l'individu
qui a appelé les deux membres des forces
armées canadiennes avec son véhicule
inconnu les autorités fédérales les
autorités ont confirmé que certains
éléments indiquent clairement qu'il
s'agit de l'individu qui s'est
radicalisée un possible attentat donc
qui survient alors que encore vendredi
les hauts gradés de la défense nationale
reconnaissait qu'il craignait justement
que des membres des forces armées
canadiennes des militaires soient ciblés
par des sympathisants islamistes
justement à cause de l'engagement du
canada en irak alors bien sûr tout ça a
suscité toutes sortes de réactions à
ottawa oui plusieurs il ya beaucoup
députés d'opposition qui s'inquiète qui
se demandent pourquoi monsieur harper a
commenté aussi rapidement sans que
vraiment l' enquête soit plus avancé
qu'on un portrait plus complet certains
lui reprochent même de vouloir créer un
climat de peur au canada surtout la
question se pose a pas si longtemps les
autorités les responsables du
renseignement répéter aux canadiens oui
il ya soixante trois enquêtes en cours
qui vise 90 individus mais tout ça est
maîtrisé et cetera là ce soit on se
demande pourquoi est ce que cet homme là
est justement passé ans clément et
comment est ce qu il a pu justement
pouvoir passer à l'acte si je vous
laisse écouter les ministres et jason
kenny et la néo démocrate hélène
laverdière
il ya toujours le menace est réelle et
nous ne nous accordons beaucoup de
confiance dans les agences de sécurité
de prévenir les attentats mais c'est
impossible de les empêcher totalement
comment ça se fait que cet individu là
aient pu se rendre dans cette situation
là on nous parle de parler beaucoup dans
d'aussi de l'irak de gens qui auraient
même qui seraient revenus qui auraient
même commis des crimes et
qui serait au canada puis on se dit ça
mais si on analyse la présence de ce
genre au canada comment ça se fait que
les autorités compétentes n'ont pas agi
haddad
ces liens se sont toutes des questions
qui seront probablement posez
certainement au commissaire à la grc bob
porcine qui est justement attendu sur la
colline du parlement demain pour
témoigner dans un comité parlementaire
sur un tout autre sujet oui beaucoup de
questions merci beaucoup et manuelles et
nous on va poursuivre la discussion
justement avec stéphane bertheau mais
analystes dans la sphère policière ces
femmes bonsoir alors vous avez entendu
ces questions comment at il pu passer à
travers les mailles du filet si on
savait qu'il était si on savait qu'ils
étaient radicaliser oui la question
qu'on n'a pas encore posé c est ce qu il
fait partie de ces enquêtes qui ont été
annoncées justement par les autorités et
moi les questions que je me pose
aujourd'hui avec cette intervention en
chambre justement à quoi servait cette
intervention en chambre parce qu'elle a
mis quand même une certaine pression sur
les épaules de l'ice cul qui enquête
actuellement et qui à ce moment même
n'avait pas encore annoncé qu'il
s'agissait d'un acte potentiellement
terroristes est-ce que ça servait
peut-être à désamorcer la situation
parce qu'on avait des éléments sur cet
individu et qu'on était en train
d'enquêter sur lui et que peut-être il
aurait échappé c'est une hypothèse il ya
des limites là dans l'état de droit dans
un état de droit comme le nôtre à ce
qu'on peut faire là comme surveillance
pour un individu et c'est vrai que bien
entendu c'est toujours l' équilibre
entre les moyens qu'on va mettre et la
dangerosité du personnage il va falloir
qu'on comprenne beaucoup mieux ce
dossier qu'on comprenne beaucoup mieux
la personnalité l'implication les
raisons et les motivations d'implication
de cet homme là dans sa démarche
terroriste puisque l'on peut l'appeler
comme tel aujourd'hui pour savoir si les
policiers ont bien mis les moyens s'ils
ont été jusqu'au niveau où ils devaient
aller vous savez les policiers
surveillent on nous annonce un nombre
d'individus mais il y en a évidemment
plus est ce qu'ils ont les moyens de les
surveiller ça c'est un gros problème
vous savez qu'on a annoncé ya pas très
longtemps que l'on voulait donner plus
de moyens aux crs pour justement
surveiller ses combattants
cette facebook c'est ça on voit la page
facebook de de cet homme ahmed rouleau
ou ahmed le converti et on voit
d'ailleurs sur sa page facebook il ya
des vidéos qui sont très radicale qui
met en scène des jihadistes donc il n'ya
pas de doute sur ses sur sûre en tout
cas ses intentions a légué après il va
falloir qu'on comprenne pourquoi et
comment il s'est radicalisé ans qu'il a
eus du support s qui s'est fait aider ou
est-ce qu'il s'est fait pousser ou
est-ce qu'il a simplement réagi à cet
appel justement au jihad dont on a
entendu parce que là ça serait le
premier incident depuis le premier
accident enfin c'est grave quand même
depuis l'appel du groupe armé état
islamique contre les pays occidentaux
membres de la coalition juste après le
début des frappes aériennes exactement
si jamais ça s'avérait est bon pour
l'instant tout nous laisse à penser
qu'il s'agit d'un acte terroriste avec
julie des motivations qui restent encore
est clairement à déterminer il est
évident que ce serait le premier
puisqu'il ya eu plusieurs autres
tentatives mais qui ont été déjoués
notamment aux pays bas en australie très
récemment 14 arrestation par la police
australienne d'individus qu'il faut le
signaler on est dans le même mode
opératoire d'individus qui visait des
policiers dans des tentatives
d'attentats ou de tentatives de meurtre
donc on va prendre ça très au sérieux et
je pense que aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
essaie de mieux comprendre ce dossier
pour voir ses implications mais là on
est quand même dans un autre univers là
des gestes terroriste des actes
terroristes ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que on est dans une nouvelle phase
de l'action terroriste et ça va
d'ailleurs nous amener certainement nous
intéresser nous nous questionner sur
qu'est-ce qu'un acte de terrorisme
aujourd'hui parce qu'on est face à des
individus qui ne se radicalise plus dans
des réseaux avec des structures
organisées quirky vont forcément sur un
terrain d'opération pour en revenir oui
en a oui ces gens là sont des recruteurs
potentiels oui ce sont des gens qui
incite les autres à se radicaliser mais
il y en a qui se radicalise avec twitter
par facebook simplement au contact de
d'individus sur internet par des
discussions
et ces individus là sont les plus
dangereux qui sont les plus difficiles à
détecter justement par leur absence de
lien avec ses réseaux ses fans berthomé
merci beaucoup pour ce site
sur merci